Flames licked the sides of the tower
Block in the north Kensington area 200
firefighters have been battling the
blaze for hours thank you Ramadan
thank you for Ramadan
it's not about Christians
but everyone's like this is a family
it's not about that but but the
government is trying to say you know all
the stories all the newspapers
[Music]
these are these are people's lives
these are families my children's teacher
is missing
and they they just push past and barred
past the police run to the tower
blockers started screaming at people and
trying to help them they ran into the
building if it wasn't for all these
young Muslim boys round here helping us
coming from mosque
that people would have dead enough more
people would have dead
enough more people they want to talk
about them when they do wrong and all
these kind of things when they're doing
bad when they're doing good that you
they were the first people with bags of
water giving to people helping people
running and telling people other parts
of London from all of London
all over all of London not just from our
estate
down by Edward Woods all over came out
with water we don't care what people are
we love them all the time we all mix
together but thank you Ramadan thank you
for Ramadan
[Music]
foreign